my name is David Pincus and I'm a
graduate student at UCSF and I get the
privilege today to interview my PhD
advisor Peter Walter on his scientific
and extra scientific hobbies and
creative endeavors so I Peter I David
think you should be in the lab well I'm
glad you find other uses of your time
yeah I'm working on the next paper it'll
be out soon so I want to start basically
by introducing what you do which is
mostly science but a little bit on the
side getting to do creative projects
with your hands doing woodworking and
metalworking doing sculpture and
functional stuff around the house so how
did you get your start doing wood and
metal working but basically started when
I was growing up when I always left to
do little projects and did a lot of
handiwork with my dad we had a little
room in our apartment in Berlin that
that was really really the tiniest Roman
in the apartment some maybe six feet by
eight feet or something and we used it
to to just do all sorts of projects it
was a room that was okay to make a mess
and to leave projects have finished
stand around and I just just love
creating things with my hands well how'd
you get your start doing science but all
she started with my dad as well when he
had a little chemist shop in Berlin and
they were selling all sorts of herbs and
chemicals and soaps and stuff and I got
fascinated by the chemistry of sort of
mixing things together making them
explode take an oxidant reductant you
can create amazing things
I suppose the pirate technical aspects
of chemistry that really got me excited
as a young boy have you ever had an idea
to use your mind ever wonder to science
when you're actually you know crafting
something of course yeah yeah when does
the to a crane not separate and often
women building things and repetitive
tasks you sit there for hours standing
something and that time this is not
raced it your neurons are firing left
and right and you put other things
together so it's a very relaxing
exercise so I think having some passion
that you can pursue outside of the lab
it's really important for keeping
yourself focused on science oh
absolutely even when we were living like
I did or photography simply because the
surroundings or that beautiful things
you can photograph in New York and I but
but when I worked in a lab myself I had
a lot of manual satisfaction by doing
experiments and I really loved the
detective work of designing experiments
and tickling outlast the secret out of
mother nature and that is know that the
lab has grown and I'm basically not on
the bench anymore I sit all day in a
computer i talk to people so I think
I've fulfilled I've need and provide
balance between the intellectual
exercise of doing something this your
hand both sides benefit from from that
creative from having creative outlets so
you have a wonderful shop here in your
house how did how did that get started
what was your first piece of equipment
that you had here and how is it taking
shape and evolved over the years but let
me step back one one one step further
when I came to the States I spent six
years in Manhattan and we were basically
living in a little box so this this kind
of art form of doing woodworking was
completely out of the question because
just couldn't didn't have the space
where where you could make good working
so dirty is it dirty exercise so
move to San Francisco we had three
requirements for a house you wanted a
fireplace we wanted a garden and I
wanted a garage and the garage basically
turned into a wood shop we evicted the
car and the Carson when the driveway and
we build a little a little wood shop and
bought a lot of used equipment that
eventually got a bit more fancy and
complete set of of doing things so I've
never took any formal training and
cabinetmaking it it's all trial and
error lots of error I want to ask you
about some of the particular specific
pieces that you have around the house
can you talk about the stained glass
piece on the on the stairs now that was
a wonderful little project that it
together with Patricia my wife when we
moved into the house really we built
this wall in which served the glass
window is now and it looked very ugly
just having of aldaran decided to
penetrate it to bring light into both
spaces so we just was our first and only
stained glass piece we we ever made and
we are quite fun exploring it I think it
turned out fantastically what about the
the tree in the bathroom the tree in the
bathroom where we experimented a lot
with lighting in the upper floor so we
put the skylights in and if you have
such a nice skylight plants are happy
there so it's a little bit the bathroom
is designed a little bit Japanese
architecture in mind very where you
where you find combination of natural
elements and geometric elements so can
you tell us about the this endeavor you
have right behind you here where you
looks like you somehow busted through
the wall to create a little habitat yeah
I grew up in Germany and all this the
houses are stone so living here in a
wooden house gives you a lot more of
what's your energy so basically what
vibrated is the friend of mine you just
took a chainsaw to the wall and
we went through cut this hole put a
little planter in on the outside and
then build this little display look here
it's just a it's just a very warm
feature one of the nice aspects at least
for me being in the lab is getting to
see some of the gifts that you craft for
our annual holiday party how did that
tradition start I always think it's it's
it's nice to give something personal the
store-bought that's generally suggest
personal gesture to think of a present
its that's befitting the person's done a
number of different things the thing I'm
most proud of is it's a time machine
again because it relates so nicely to
the science we do the thing we are the
most precious thing we have this is our
time and this machine makes more of it
just take this clock and squeeze it out
trips time and then you have a bottle of
it to use for whatever gives you rewards
and satisfaction the fountains in the
garden are beautiful when what was the
order that that you put them together
and can you describe that process yes I
love flowing water I mean it's wonderful
in landscape design sing a wonderful
example is y'all hambro in Granada in
Spain so this is the center of Islamic
culture it's a palace there's lots of
water features left and right trying to
build some water features into our
garden it's very relaxing sitting next
to flowing water the ball fountain I was
at a scientific meeting conference in
santa fe and tommy kirk house in and i
went to a gallery stone forest we they
have wonderful craft or stone features
then we had a big a big issue because
you suddenly get this crate with a round
stone ball that wastes themselves and
pounds and it sits in your garage in
your driveway then what do you do next
it's so a lot of handling logistics of
how to then put it out there in the
garden so I built cranes and cots and
and tracks to move it out so in part
what i love about creating things is to
deal with the challenges as I arise and
it's a process the window fountain again
it has a little oriental touch in design
was just sketched another boring seminar
and has very dramatic features to it a
little pond and Ernie's with our goat
fish and it's it's it's a search the the
third generation of that glass plate
fountain so the first one was
experimental very basic we try to pump
up the water between two glass plates
and it's it's amazing what eight feet of
pressure does to a glass plate so it
basically exploded Hartman when we try
to pump the water in there then the
second one was was better was we'd had
copper piping on the side hidden inside
the wood which then flew over in a storm
and this is the circuit version now and
it has a valid stainless steel frame
hidden inside the wood so it looks very
delicate it's actually quite strong with
the inside I guess started with woodwork
and now it seems that your time trying
your hand at metalwork so can you
describe a little bit about la Monique
yes hola muneca soar to sculpture that
is eventually going to be a fountain
woodworking is is a subtractive craft
because you take a piece of wood and you
carve away from it and then you glue a
few things together but there will
always be separate pieces there is metal
jerking especially welding you put
things together you form feminine points
of synthetic
and I think the two the two are various
they're fundamentally different and you
can create things in metal you could
never dream of building building in wood
expanded range of possibilities enhancer
did the ultimate to be mr. combine the
two so I want to make kinetic sculptures
that look wooden at half metal interiors
that I've working that that the wooden
pieces interacted p in ways that are
just what possible was that material
along so how did you get your
inspiration for lawmen eek was sitting
there doodling and my mind was wandering
into some geometrical shapes that would
make some nice sculpture I think that
were the first sketches that then
evolved it basically what she is she's a
little square that then expands when you
twist the whole thing and turn it over
and then a couple a couple of months
later I i I've read a book the day of
the triffids by John Minton science
fiction novel written in the 1950s where
we're sort of plant-like creature start
invading the earth and fester being
cultured as beautiful exotic new plants
and then when everybody has them in
their garden they turn out carnivorous
and start attacking and eating people
it's a one-er wonderful little story and
it's so sorry Sam everyone can turn her
into something like that so I tried to
make the sculpture more and more organic
looking on super imposed on the on the
geometrical design
how does your science and your art how
does these two things sort of inform
each other and and influence is there an
interplay between the two well i mean i
think if you think that's what what what
makes you a great scientist is basically
doing something well and being creative
with what you're doing going into going
somewhere out of the box where people
haven't been before because you're busy
doing discovery no idea where we're
going sink in a way working working with
material and creating something is
actually quite similar I think in both
in science and and and art you're never
going to be computer a fully rewarded by
just doing something technically perfect
if it's just derivative of what other
people have done
you